turning to afghanistan where the taliban
says it's speaking directly to the u.s
about building relations more than a
month after american and foreign forces
withdrew but in an interview with al
jazeera the taliban's foreign affairs
spokesman denounced u.s drone operations
in afghan airspace
their violation of our territorial
integrity of afghanistan
it is a blatant and a clear violation
it is against
the commitments that the united states
of america made
in the doha agreement
the doha agreement clearly stipulates
that
the united states and
other countries as well
its allies will not interfere
in the internal affairs of afghanistan
they are not only violating their own
commitments but they are also violating
international law
for more on this let's go live now to
hashimoto who is in kabul hashem so on
the one hand the taliban is denouncing
u.s activity
in afghan airspace but but is also
speaking directly with washington what
which should we make of all of this
well basically kim this
shows the dilemma that all the parties
are facing in afghanistan the taliban
took over they won the war but suddenly
they found themselves grappling with how
to run the country they need resources
they need cash they need assets that are
frozen in the u.s they need the
international recognition to be able to
move forward in the absence of that they
will have a huge problem financial and
political and one day they won't be able
to feed their own people and this
explains why they are desperate for
international recognition they had high
hopes that the americans would step in
but the americans are waiting to see
whether the taliban of today are not the
taliban of 1996 when they first took
over
the country and this explains why on one
hand the taliban are upset with the
americans because they have intercepted
what they say are drones which have been
flying over the airspace of afghanistan
and they say this should stop but at the
end of the day we've been told by many
taliban officials that there are direct
talks with the americans and they're
hoping to convince the americans to deal
with the taliban for them that will be a
cornerstone that would pave the way for
more stability in afghanistan
hashem in this interview it was also
discussed the rights of of women and
girls
uh and their civic engagement or role in
civic society what was said on that
front
well i have to say there is
there seems to be a divide within the
taliban about how to tackle issues
particularly
giving women a bigger say in the
government women's role and gender
segregation
and the decision to put restrictions on
girls education and to deny
female secondary students from going to
school has backfired in a way or another
even those who've been asking to end the
isolation of taliban like qatar and
pakistan have been very critical lately
of the taliban saying that it's about
time for the taliban to understand that
there are realities on the ground they
have to readjust with they have to
reinvent themselves to be able to move
forward and this explains why
when when i spoke with abdul al-qahab
the spokesman of the taliban's minister
foreign affairs
he is saying exactly that he we should
give the taliban some time to figure out
how to move forward let's listen to what
he had to say
we have committed and we have guaranteed
all the rights
that have been afforded to women in
islam
that is their right to education their
right to health care their right to work
and
they
the the process
that the world wants us
uh
the steps they once want us to take we
are taking them we have seen progress in
them we understand all the complexities
of of the
of the current world
we understand it very well and we are
working
but again i must emphasize that
as the saying goes rome was not built in
a day
we understand the world we understand
the different complex political
realities as abdul qahar balahi said
but then we have to tell
our viewers that in 1996 when the
taliban took over they were a different
group run by one single person the emir
alma minero the commander of the
faithful mullah roma along with tribal
leaders and clerics and then they had a
different version a different worldview
about how afghanistan should stand they
thought that a puritanical conservative
society would be the best way to protect
afghanistan today you have different
views within the taliban you have those
who say
we've been doing business with different
key players in the world and we have to
understand that if we don't reinvent
ourselves we will never be able to move
forward but you have those
hard-line taliban leaders those from the
1996 era who still say that if we make
concessions when it comes to identity
sharia allah islamic laws giving women
more freedom that could
undermine our reputation but that also
could create some sense of uh uh
discourse among the uh the conservatives
who remain i have to say the backbone of
the taliban movement will they be able
to set aside those differences and move
forward well i don't know at this
particular moment but from talking to
many many taliban leaders they do
understand that this time
the options left for them are very few
and there's absolutely no way they can
move forward and get international
recognition if they don't make
concessions
thank you for that update in kabul